hearts will be most susceptible
and most open to the book of
Allah and the son of the
prophet this is called
Shar Hasadar literally
translates to opening the chest
But we know that the chest and
the heart, they are
interchangeable in the Quran.
We spoke about this before,
correct? That when Allah
mentions the chest, he's
referring as well to the heart.
And when he mentions the heart,
he's referring as well to the
chest. Correct? And that there
are three terms that Allah uses
in the Quran to refer to the
heart. There is
right? All of these refer to
the heart. So, when we say we
mean, we mean open heart. We
mean having an open heart but
if Allah mentions together in
the same sentence, then they
mean different things. And
that's a different issue. It it
is a verse in
the
[Silence]
Islam. He says, hence, whomever
Allah chooses to and decide and
and desires to guide, he will
open his heart to Islam. That
is the proper translation.
Sometimes, we will find
translations that are too
literal and what I mean by
literal is they will literally
translate every word and not
and overlook thee intended
meaning, intended meaning,
right? So, the literal
translation would be, whomever
Allah desires to guide He will
open his chest to Islam. Now,
listen to the difference here.
He will open his chest to
Islam. Whomever Allah desires
to guide, he will open his
heart to Islam. Which one is
more correct? A heart, correct?
That's what's intended by chest
here. If somebody who speaks
English says, he will open his
chest to Islam. They will say,
what would, what does that
mean? Open his chest. The
literal translation of is to
literally cut open the chest.
Is that what is intended?
Whomever Allah desires to
guide, he will cut open his
chest. Does that what that
means? No. What's intended is,
whomever Allah chooses to
guide, he will open his hard to
Islam, right? He will open his
heart to Islam And it is
referred to as
opposed to because the heart is
the most important aspect of
what is in the chest. Right? So
when Allah speaks about opening
the chest, it means opening the
heart. Because the heart is the
most value thing that is in the
chest and the only reason you
would open the chest is to get
to the heart. This is why he
refers to it in this way. The
point here is that
Islam, whomever Allah chooses
to guide and and desires,
guidance for, will open his
heart to Islam. Only Islam,
Islam, Issan, Iman, a deen the
religion, all of that is
intended, right? So, we spoke
about, he he list ten things
that are causes for the heart
to become open to, to Islam.
Now, with the intensity of
these causes, comes the
intensity of the opening of the
heart. Am I making sense with
that statement? With the
intensity of these causes,
comes the intensity of the
opening of the heart. and with
thee weakness of these causes
comes the weakness of the
opening of the heart right?
Which means very simply,
the
So the
[Silence]
the religion, Islam, the Iman,
Iqsan, all of these things are
what are what are intended. The
light of Allah, all of this is
synonymous. So, he may, he
lists 10 things. We discussed
six of those ten things We
discussed at Tawheed. We
discussed the light that Allah
places in the person's heart.
We discussed knowledge,
beneficial knowledge of the
which has been passed down from
the Prophet Muhammad We
discussed
We discussed turning to Allah
and loving him with the
entirety of the heart. And
facing and basically striving
towards Allah and finding
solace and peace and comfort in
the and and finding pleasure
for that matter in the worship
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
We discuss this as well.
He says continuously
remembering Allah in any state
and in any place and we also
discussed this as well. Now we
he also mentions whenever
we discussed last week showing
kindness, mercy, gentleness
too, the creation of Allah,
benefiting them with whatever a
person is able to benefit the
creatures of Allah whether that
be with his wealth or his
reputation or his body.
Meaning, to physically help
somebody. Any of these things
and these are just examples. A
person can help people with
their with their speech, help
people with their with his
reputation. A person can help
people with his wealth. A
person can help people with his
lineage. A person can help
people. Many many things,
correct? This is a cause for
the heart to become opened to
the light of Allah Now, before
we continue, I want to mention
something. And that is, that,
Not all people are the same.
Not all hearts are the same and
not all people are able to
reach. They are not oh wired to
have the same abilities and
same amount of a man as other
people. There's a difference.
Just there's a difference
in our physical capabilities.
Just there's difference in
our mental capacities. There
are some people who are more
intelligent than others and
there are some people who are
more well memorized than
others. There are people who
have stronger memories. There
are people that have stronger
understanding, correct? All of
this is correct. However, the
same goes for the person's
capacity with regards to the
light of Allah So, for example,
I have a question to ask Let's
say the prophet Muhammad
he was taken on he was taken to
the heavens and spoken to by
Allah and shown paradise and
shown the hellfire etcetera.
would a regular average
individual have the capacity to
see these things? Huh?
No, the answer is no. The
answer is no. Perhaps, if one
of our, one of us were taken
on, they may lose their mind.
It may be too much for them.
Their heart is not able to
accept or able to comprehend
all of these things.
Is that, is that, is that
notion clear? Where am I
getting this from? Well, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala gives an
example of the heart and the
hearts of men. In
So, he mentions that
and
methal, Lil Quran,
[Silence]
equal in their body and their
physical strength and not
everyone is equal in their, in
their mental and intellectual
strength. And not everyone is
equal in their, in their
ability to accept and
completely fulfill thee, thee,
and accept all of the light of
the Quran. Each, each heart
will accept to its capacity.
Each heart can accept to its
capacity but the hearts of men
are different. There are hearts
which are larger. There are
hearts which are, not as large.
There are hearts which are more
understanding and more
compelled and there are hearts
which are less compelled. And
we see this difference, not all
of the scholars, even if they
all memorize the Quran are all
the same. There are some who
are more understanding, more ad
herent, more more able to,
fulfill its commandments,
etcetera, and there are those
are not so much, not less and
likewise, there are those who
have stronger memories of the
Quran in the Sunnah and there
are those who have lesser. And
likewise, there are those who
have more ad herence to the
Quran in others. They're not
all the same. And the
companions were not all the
same as well. Where the
companions all exactly the same
and amen? No. We're the
prophets and messengers all
exactly the same in Iman. No.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
these messengers, we have given
them various levels and we have
raised some above others. Raise
some above others in what? And
amen.
their understanding
in what they were given of
revelation, etcetera. And this
will also root to the reward a
person will have. Correct? The
reward a person will have. So,
the prophet Muhammad said,
the
[Silence]
emphatically
emphatically mentioned in their
books of and that is that
the
that
[Silence]
real and the same as the Iman
of the rest of the angels. It
are is the Iman of the Prophet
Muhammad equal is are is the
Iman of Abu Bakr Sadiq. The
best of mankind after the
prophets. Is his Iman equal to
the Iman of the Prophet
Muhammad huh? No. Not even in
his belief in Allah and the
last day and the angels and the
books and the the day of
resurrection and the the basic
constructs of Iman, it is still
varies. There are those who
believe in them stronger and
there are those who believe in
them. Less, less, with, with
less strength, So, what does
this mean? This means that the
hearts have different
capacities They have different
capacities and we see this with
the prophets and messengers and
we see this as well with whom
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala chose
to be the companions of the
prophet Muhammad
he said, Allah looked into the
hearts of all of mankind and
chose Mohammed.
And then he looked in the
hearts of all of mankind and
chose his companions to be, his
companions. Due to the depth of
their knowledge and the breath
of their wisdom, and the
strength of their faith. So
Allah chose these men to be his
companion. He didn't choose us.
We'll never be the
companions in faith but we
mimic them. Correct? We we
imitate them. We imitate the
companions. Can we ever be like
the prophets? Ever? No. But do
we imitate them? Yes, we
imitate them. Because imitating
the best makes you, gives you a
luster. and gives you an honor
even if you cannot catch up to
them, you will at least be
considered of them.
Is this
a clear concept? I
think this is pretty clear,
right? And so, The same thing
goes with the companions. Not
all of them are the same. and
the same thing goes with the
the generation after the
companions and the companions
themselves. They're not the
same. No tabity. Right? And
there is a difference of
opinion amongst the scholars as
to who the most superior of the
are is. There's a difference of
opinion. Some say it's
some say it is.
but regardless of who it is,
the point is, is that, will
these men ever be to the level
of a companion? What is the
answer? Never. They could never
be. No matter how much
knowledge they have. Why is
this Allah mentions this in his
book
[Silence]
Rawi.
authentic is that the person
who heard it from the prophet
is actually a companion. If we
know he is a companion, even if
we have no information about
him but we are positive, he is
a companion. Then, that is
enough. We don't need to know
his history. We don't need to
know his legacy. Contrary to
the the generation that came
after the companions, The
generation came after the
companions We have to research
who they are and if we don't
know who they are, we cannot we
cannot conclude that this
narration is authentic. Until
we know who they are and we are
sure that the conditions of
accepting transmission of
hadith are fulfilled in this
individual. Until we have that,
we cannot, we cannot judge the
narration to be authentic but
that is contrary to if a person
is a companion. If it is a
companion, we don't need to
know anything about him. Even
if we have one sentence about
him, that's enough. As long as
it is sure that he was a
companion. Why? Why is it that
the people that came after the
companions are so stringently
researched and looked after
whilst the companions, they get
a free pass, it seems. As long
as they're a companion, we
accept their narration. Why? At
Imam he says, the reason for
this is because
merely seeing the prophet and
having believed in him, ignites
a flame and a light in the
heart that is unmatched by
anything that can be that can
be had after him.
because Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala in more than one verse
in the Quran, he
coupled the Quran and the
prophet together as two
independent miracles. Does this
mean that the prophet is
superior to the Quran? No, of
course not. That's not what
we're saying. The Quran is a is
a is part of the attributes of
Allah. Is uncreated. The
prophet is a creation of Allah.
There there there is no contest
there. The point is is that
Allah mentions the prophet
along with the Quran as two
independent. As two independent
miracles which articulates that
the Prophet Muhammad is a an
extremely grand miracle. Of
Allah And this is in more than
one verse in the Quran. In the
book of Allah where he will
mention the Quran and mention
the prophet
In one verse he says and that
which means and how can you
disbelieve? And the verses of
Allah are recited unto you and
between you amongst you is his
messenger. So Allah doesn't
mention one miracle He mentions
two. So Allah mentions the
Prophet Muhammad and the Quran
together as two independent
miracles. Does this not raise
the status of the prophet
Muhammad Of course, abundantly.
Therefore, therefore, when we
speak about Iman, when we speak
about the heart being open,
when we speak about when we
speak about opening the heart,
accepting the light of Allah,
accepting thee, guidance of
Allah, levels of faith, people
are not the same. They are not
the same and they do not have
the same capacities. The
prophet said that there are
many levels in paradise,
correct? And Allah mentions
this as well in the Quran. the
so there are many levels of
paradise and Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and the and the prophet
said, that whoever hears the
repeats after the and then
makes a salah upon me, and then
asks Allah for me
This individual will surely
attain my intercession on the
day of resurrection. What is he
says? is a place in paradise
that is not befitting except
for one person. And I am
hopeful that I will be that one
person. Meaning the levels of
paradise they
The levels of paradise, they
are kind of imagine a
cone. okay? There is the lower
levels of paradise and as it
gets up, it becomes, it
becomes, more and more strict
with regards to the criteria of
those who will enter paradise,
will enter that level. I'm
speaking about I'm not speaking
about space. It's not smaller
as you go up. It's it's broader
as you go up, okay? I'm
speaking about criteria. When a
person wants to raise a level
in paradise, they're the their
criteria to enter that higher
level becomes more and more and
more burdensome and strict,
correct? He says, and there is
a place in the highest level of
paradise, that is only
befitting for one person Only
one person is eligible for that
place. And I hope I am hopeful
that it will be me. right? So,
this is this articulates to us
that people are of different
levels in faith. Just like
people are of different levels
in in disbelief. is Abu Talib
and Abu Lahab the same? No.
about who who was closer to
Islam Abu Talib, correct? And
who was further from Islam?
Likewise, who was stronger in
faith? Is is and and Hamza.
faith? No. Who is stronger in
faith? Hamza. Correct?
and who comes after him? Al
Abbas. Muslim and and he's from
the and he was and he was
martyred etcetera etcetera.
Abaz became Muslim later,
later, wave war later. So, the
point here is that people are
not the same in faith and they
are not the same in evil and
wickedness. There are levels
and that's why there are levels
in paradise and levels into
hellfire. Correct?
it's important for us to
understand this issue as we
continue with regards to the
capacity of the human heart and
the variations of the different
hearts of men with regards to
accepting, embraceing, and ad
hering to the light of Allah
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. And the
ability to do so. Just like
some can lift heavier things
than others. Likewise, some
hearts are more capable of
carrying more knowledge and
amen than others
That is the, it it boils down
to being the, the bounty of
Allah, whom he disperses to
whomever he chooses. Subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]